so we're going to be filming you two
separately and see how your answers
differ
okay cool well they're going to be so
different okay are you ready
i am so ready yep let's do it how often
do you have
maybe like five times a week once a week
once or twice a week
honestly maybe like once a week she
might lie to you and say that we do it
all the time we have
24 7. 365 days
but that's a lie how often do you have
typically
once a week once a week usually on
sundays after our nap
a little nap time on sundays that's
where we are after 12 years
describe your life in three words
spontaneous hot
different funny fun kinky what makes it
kinky
um we recently started with
water sports and piss play and stuff
on the yellow background
did he say water
what's that one they make them squirt
trans oh
i didn't know i didn't know today's
episode is sponsored by bluechew
bluechu gives you the first chewable
with the same
fda approved active ingredients as vagra
or
cialis it's prescribed online by
licensed physicians so you don't have to
go to the doctor and wait in line
and it's even cheaper than a pharmacy
and they prepare it and ship it right to
you
in a discreet package you don't have to
worry about nobody coming through like
oh what's that
and you don't even have to leave your
house which during these times let's be
honest so right now we got a special
promo gwan
visit bluechu.com and use promo code
abba and get your first shipment free
don't make any mistakes make the right
decision you want to enhance your lives
you don't want to be like some of these
couples that you're watching in this
video
then get on blue chew spice it up you
don't need to do any p-play
you don't need to be doing any water
squirting water sports none of that
blue chew it's blue like water but it's
blue in a good way
is that hard to say just yeah i've never
like talked about it i don't know
it's it's hot who's better in bed me
uh i am i mean i've
i've had slightly more experience i
think i'm better and better
i think she's gonna say that she's
better in bed i'm definitely better at
sex i try to be nice but you know what
it's not
we're not gonna be nice about it i think
she's just gonna say these things to
look cool
i gotta strap that thing on i do that i
do everything
hey you know she's lazy matter of fact
she won't do name who's better in bed
i feel like me i lay it down pretty hard
he's like the muscle
like i'm the brains behind do you think
she's lazy i don't think she's lazy i
think she's comfortable
and that's okay i'm just having a good
time having my lady
up until now he's only been with vanilla
people
so i would say i'm probably like the
freakier more experienced one
well she does a good job of what she
does so i'll give her the nod there
between you two who's more
it's definitely me my husband is
definitely more special than i am i
think we're pretty equal we're both
trans men on testosterone we always want
to have sex with each other i think i
initiate more
i don't know bro i don't know i just
listen i
told you hey man no no it's interesting
i don't know it's a lot it's just like
it's just information constantly
squirting at me you know
[Laughter]
well you can put your cap on
and get the [ __ ] out
[Laughter]
what's your favorite position when he
puts my legs up over his shoulders he'll
say
oh doggy doggy doggy style i don't want
him to say doggy style because it's just
so cliche everybody's going to say doggy
style
you know doggy style the view is great
it's a
very versatile classic pose how would
you rate your sex life
on a scale of one to ten one ten fifteen
i think it's a ten now because we can
communicate when we first started dating
it was about like a four and a half or
five it was her first time being like
wild and kinky because when someone's
asking you to like
can i put my toes in you or you know
it's kind of weird for her
everybody likes different things so you
have to you have to learn
and so now what happens is she just
fully committed to the phone oh yeah
she's
she's fully committed to the toe stuff
like she loves it she says i have pretty
feet
i probably shouldn't have said that
she's going to be so upset in terms of
like what we do sexy
good it's more of like you know having
to kind of like
push it to the side having sex quietly
like super late at night or
a respectable hour in the morning before
the kids wake up
how would you rate your life on a scale
of one to ten i would rate my
life at an eight i would like it to be a
little bit more spontaneous
i don't think we've really done more
than three positions i could probably
be a little more creative bring some
toys in i have bought a dildo and
he hasn't used it on me at all do you
have a deldo or anything
uh tony has one he's never brought it
into the bedroom
could twice help yes i can't climax
without toys
close your eyes we're going to hand you
different toys and you're going to say
if you'd want to use it or not
okay i'm excited hold on
and you got yeah go ahead put it on me
that's literally look at this look at
the hands
the wife beater is waiting for um okay
uh
i hope it's a womanizer yeah i want the
foot
man don't put no weird [ __ ] in my hand
okay i'm sorry i can't promise that
[Music]
oh these are handcuffs oh oh hell yeah
yes
ten out of ten use these would use these
i mean it's really not my thing
i know he wouldn't want it on him i
would we have some
not this style i don't like the style
but yes i would use them totally she was
wearing them
oh i'd make her wear them i've been
arrested so many times
so i don't i don't even want these kids
i'm getting flashbacks here wait do you
have the key
no would you would you use handcuffs
i wouldn't use handcuffs i could see
this thing right like
i could just put my hands up and
simulate that
rather than needing to actually be i'm
not doing anything i'm not doing
anything i'm not doing
i'm not doing whips either can i just do
no slave master fantasy nope no no no no
humming in bed
dude all right i don't even know what
this is oh
this is like anal beads this is a
vibrating one i think right yeah
it looks like it kind of hurt yeah so
yeah do you think she'll say yes i know
she'll say yeah
probably not we haven't used these yet
but
i feel like he would be all for it on me
not on him
would you use it on yourself oh [ __ ] all
right
i don't know man this girl's a lot
different than all the ones i've been
with so
honestly i probably would
that's interesting the thrusting thing
is really intriguing
not too much work it's a good size
yes i would like to try this i don't
even know what this is
oh whoa whoa
yes this is nice this is nice
this is very nice oh my gosh
yeah i think this one's a yes yeah
definitely use this
oh this is heavy damn oh yeah
oh it's so heavy i love this
oh my god the thing is gigantic would
you use that
no no i don't think
so what the [ __ ] is this would you
introduce that into the bedroom yes
100 yes i don't think either of us like
gaping very much
so probably not did he say yes
i think it's more of a no did he say no
that's something that we'll have to talk
about adam and eve is offering a 50
discount we should do our own adam and
eve
we're big ass dildos and hey oh
forget adam and eve when you got
having preach
fifty percent is off like this
for the right amount of money we just
gonna show up at your door so it'll be a
lot of money but yeah i mean you know
but
you know in the past we did that for
less you know for poutine maybe
that's uh it was interesting i like this
video
no this is a good video um it's
interesting to see like just some of the
different answers between two i don't
think there's any like
drama per se the older the couple is the
longer the couple have been together the
similar the more similar to
the answers that's just not normal yeah
sinking they sync they think their
answers too
yeah definitely it makes perfect sense
so it was cool to watch that
um the trans stuff was throwing me off a
little bit i just wasn't used to hearing
all the stuff gaping
p play and um
well i have a podcast though
that one i know people do stuff and i've
seen
but it's just like i'll pass
have you have you watched all those
videos i've watched some gnarly videos
yeah i've seen you ever seen the uh
bme pain olympics yeah
i've seen uh yeah bruh there was a time
on the internet where everything was
everywhere wild wild i'm going to censor
that way i'm not going to let you guys
oh no
wow why don't you put this away it was
the olympics but it was a different kind
oh yeah it was wild things was wow there
was no gold medals there was just gold
going into things and people
holes oh all right that's it
hey hey stop thinking about this i can't
talk about the chair
that's it for today's video listen let's
think about the guy sitting in a chair
what you can't do